In the past, getting an inside look at living
bugs was difficult.
during CT scans, the critters would crawl
and squirm -- causing image smearing and artifacts.
Like many animals, insects become sedentary
when exposed to high CO2 environments, so
researchers at the University of Western Ontario
had an idea.
Scientists subjected Colorado Potato Beetles
to a constant flow of CO2.
Within seconds, the insects were not moving,
but still alive.
With the beetles immobilized, researchers
were able to get some of the clearest images
of bug guts to date.
With the exception of a few older males, the
subjects were easily woken up,
and the exposure to radiation and CO2 didn’t seem to harm the insects.
The researchers say that with this quick and
safe method of knocking out bugs, clearer
looks at insect insides are in the near future,
while still on the inside of the bug